[Music]
in 1992 iohan omar came to this country
from a refugee camp
in east africa kenya three years later
she and her family applied for and
received refugee status
in the united states five years after
that she became a u.s citizen
and she's been attacking the united
states as a racist hellhole pretty much
ever since according to omar there's
barely a difference between
this country and terrorist groups like
al qaeda
in a 2013 interview omar complained that
people seem to think there was a big
difference between america and al qaeda
watch
when i was in college i took uh a
terrorism class
every time the the the professor said
okay that he
sort of like his shoulders went up and
you know yeah
al-qaeda you know hospitals you don't
say america with an intensity you don't
say
england with an intensity you know you
don't you don't say
um the army with an intensity
so she still feels this way we know
because she recently spoke to a group
hosted by the council on american
islamic relations
care and while there the congresswoman
complained that america is bigoted
against muslims they're second-class
citizens she said
she offered no proof of that it's an
absurd claim
muslims live with far greater freedom in
america than they do in any islamic
country on the planet that's why they
move here
millions and millions more would like to
join them and you would too if you were
them
that's why congresswoman omar lives here
too and not in somalia in america by the
way
she's an elected member of congress
could she do that in saudi arabia
no is she grateful for that no she never
stops complaining
and as part of that complaining she made
this now famous remark about 9 11.
care was founded after 9 11
because they recognized that some people
did something
and that all of us were starting to lose
access to our civil liberties
some people did something but we're the
real victims here
omar's understatement attracted plenty
of criticism the new york post ran a
cover showing images of
the 9 11 attacks in case you'd forgotten
what some people did
then late last week the president joined
the criticism by tweeting this video
care was founded after 9 11
because they recognized that some people
did something
so you have no idea right i have another
one another plane just hit
some people did something
[Music]
oh my goodness there is smoke pouring
out of the pentagon
some people did something
a little over the top yeah maybe if
you're yohanamar you probably wouldn't
like that video people don't like to be
criticized
got it but would you feel physically
threatened by that tweet
well not unless you believe that
disagreement is the same as
violence and as it happens the left does
believe
that disagreement is the same as
violence or claims to believe that all
of a sudden everyone on television
is telling us that trump is trying to
hurt ilhan omar
many are calling trump's tweet and that
video an incitement
to violence against the congresswoman
donald trump
is trying to incite violence this is not
just
excitement to violence this is an
incitement
to violence the goal is inciting
violence
we are getting to the level where this
is an incitement of violence
no question is he inciting violence
towards muslims not even only ilhan omar
but muslim americans in this country
so cory booker who will say literal
literally anything
went farther of course that's a
signature move whenever everyone else is
saying something ridiculous
booker will triple down on the insanity
to pretend to be completely sincere
about it
in this case booker was happy to blame
trump for actual terror attacks
since 9 11 we've had terrorist attacks
in this country the majority of them
have been right-wing extremists and the
majority of those
have been white supremacist attacks from
a
synagogue in pittsburgh to a church in
south carolina
and these are white supremacist groups
that use language
as we saw as far away as new zealand use
our president's language
almost as if as a license for these
attacks
i swear in 20 years every fifth grader
will believe
911 was committed by white supremacists
totally true
you watched you heard it here first
they're the real threat we need to fear
and suppress them
and that's what booker's saying and to
prove it he and so many demagogues in
the left are forever telling us about
the epidemic of hate crimes
in this country but they're lying there
is no epidemic of hate crimes we check
we know what the numbers are
we checked for california the biggest
state the most liberal state here are
the numbers in 2017 the state of
california convicted a total
of 65 people of hate crimes statewide 65
out of a population of almost 40 million
people
by the way there were fewer hate crimes
in california in 2017
under trump than there were in 1996
under the bill clinton administration
that epidemic is fake it's propaganda
they're trying to control you with fear
your opinions are violence that's what
they're saying
your opinions are violence disagreeing
with me is assault
for my safety you must not be allowed to
speak you must obey
that's what they're telling you and you
can see why here's where we come into it
if we go along with this
if we accede to these demands it's over
if we let them redefine speech as
violence
the first amendment has no meaning they
can tell you what to say
and when to say it they can use any
force necessary
to make you be be quiet just as you
would do
whatever you needed to do and use
whatever force was necessary
to stop a terror attack because they're
saying your opinions
and a terror attack are the same thing
this is a scary argument and we should
we should be afraid of it